Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This piece of work tries to estimate depth
information from an input photograph. This
means that it looks at the photo and tries
to tell how far away parts of the image are
from the camera.
An example output looks like this: on the
left, there is an input photograph, and on
the right, you see a heatmap with true distance
information. This is what we're trying to
approximate.
This means that we collect a lot of indoor
and outdoor images with their true depth information,
and we try to learn the correspondence, how
they relate to each other. Sidewalks, forests,
buildings, you name it. These image and depth
pairs can be captured by mounting 3D scanners
on this awesome custom-built vehicle. And,
gentlemen, that is one heck of a way of spending
research funds.
The final goal is that we provide a photograph
for which the depth information is completely
unknown and we ask the algorithm to provide
it for us.
Here you can see some results: the first image
is the input photograph, the second shows
the true depth information. The third image
is the depth information that was created
by this technique.
And here is a bunch of results for images
downloaded from the internet. It probably
does at least as good as a human would. Spectacular.
This sounds like a sensorial problem for humans,
and a perilous journey for computers to say
the least. What is quite remarkable is that
these relations can be learned by a computer
algorithm.
What can we use this for? Well, a number of
different things, one of which is to create
multiple views of this 2D photograph using
the guessed depth information.
It can also be super helpful in building robots
that can wander about reliably with inexpensive
consumer cameras mounted on them.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!